So we've just seen how to integrate JavaScript and HTML in our interpreter
in our web browser.
Let me show you a more complicated example.
We'll see how it plays out in real life.
We often use this tag to begin a webpage.
It's not strictly necessary, but it's very good practice.
We're going to use this tag to begin a paragraph.
Just to remind us, it's possible to have comments in HTML.
The lexer strips them out, so we're not going to see them at the interpreter level.
Here I've put in a list of word elements, This is a,
and then here's a tag element, and inside it, nested are 3 more word elements
and then the tag element ends.
This is an anchor tag, making a link to Google.
Let's say I want to write a webpage about John Searle's famous
Chinese Room thought experiment, in which he argues against
or at least puts forth positions that cause one to consider artificial intelligence.
It's fun stuff.
But I don't remember exactly when he made the experiment.
I will in a totally contrived example.
Super contrived. Use Javascript to compute this.
So let's say I can't remember exactly when he came out with the Chinese Room
thought experiment, but I do know that the date was equal to 1,260 + 6 factorial.
If only there were some way I could carryout this computation on my webpage.
Whoa is me! So I've written some Javascript to do just that.
I compute 6 factorial + 1,260 and write it out and then we finish out with the rest
of our webpage text.
So this whole bit here is an embedded JavaScript fragment.
Over here, we see the final result. This is a link to Google.
John Searle's italicized Chinese Room thought experiment from 1980--
oh! that's when it was. How silly of me not to remember!--
argues against artificial intelligence.
And you may notice that since there's some space here at the end of the script,
this comma doesn't line up exactly with the 1980.
Let's not worry about that for now.